الانتباه لعناصر الحياه اليوميه اللي عم
نعيشها الان يعني هناك مفردات جديده دخلت
كيف يعني اللغه الشعريه كيف تتعامل مع هذه
الحدثات يعني الجديده التي دخلت علينا
الشاعر كما تعرف يعني ليس وعاء لتسجيل
المستجدات اللغويه اللفظيه صحيح هذه مهمه
القواميس الشاعر يلتقيط
لسه فقط المفردات ولكن يلتقط ايضا المشاعر
ويلتقط المظاهر الاخرى للغه التحكم
السخريه التامل
وهذه هي التي تجعل الشعر قادرا على خلق
لغه جديده
[موسيقى]
المغامره الشعريه والتجريب والانطلاق من
الاشياء غير المنتظره غير المتوقعه هو هذا
الذي يدفع الشعر الى
ارتياد افاق جديده والى خلق لغه جديده
وعلى فكره
التطور التطور اللغات مرتبط الى حد كبير
بتطور تجارب شعريه في هذه اللغات كثير
انها سمعت بعض السياسيين مثلا في بلادنا
يقولون نحن لحاجه لنا بالشعر وبالروايه
وبالقصه نحن في حاجه الى المهندسين والى
تقنيين والى الاطباء هذه الاشياء لسنا في
حاجه اليها فان اعدام الادب والشعر في
مجتمع هو اعدام للغه